Transcriptor: TED Translators admin
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
(Video)
El barrio de La Bollada es
un barrio de contexto de gente
que se dedica a reciclar,
hay obreros, empleadas...
Muchas veces le dicen "La Aldea" porque
es un barrio que está aislado.
En el barrio no hay un ciber, no hay
carnicerías, no hay supermercados...
Es un barrio con características
particulares,
donde el acceso a la información
se hace muy complejo.
Hoy en día, casi nadie tiene plata
para comprar una computadora.
Aparte si la compran, no pueden poner
conexión a Internet ni nada de eso.
Este es el problema de Uruguay.
El 40 % de los niños que
van a escuela pública,
vienen del quintil más pobre
de la sociedad.
Y solo el 3 % de ese quintil
ingresa a la universidad.
Yo les quiero contar, cómo
a través del plan CEIBAL
decidimos apostar a cambiar
esa situación
y buscar alguna manera de salir
de esta crisis en la que vivimos.
En el año 2005 Nicolas Negroponte
lanzó la idea "One laptop per child"
que para nosotros desde Uruguay,
un país pequeño,
decidimos que era una idea bárbara
que podíamos adaptarla, cambiarla un poco
a nuestra realidad
e innovar con ella.
Desde el primer día pensamos:
"Este es un plan de inclusión social,
este es un plan de equidad,
este es un plan que le va a permitir
dar verdaderas igualdades de oportunidades
a los niños y a los adolescentes".
Y de esa manera, sin lugar a dudas,
si podemos resolver eso estamos seguros
de que vamos a resolver los temas
educativos, los temas de aprendizaje
y la infraestructura de un país que
necesita para poder entregar computadoras.
Cuando el presidente Tabaré Vázquez
en el año 2006 anunció este plan
sin lugar a duda, tenía muchos riesgos.
Para los que no saben el presidente
Vázquez es oncólogo de profesión
por lo tanto tiene claro que
si no se asumen riesgos
difícilmente se pueden
curar los problemas.
Nosotros teníamos claro
que el único riesgo
que no podíamos asumir,
era el riesgo de no hacer nada.
Porque no haciendo nada,
sabíamos que hipotecábamos
generaciones de niños
y de jóvenes en esta situación.
¿Por qué? Es muy claro...
El sistema de gran crecimiento económico
que hemos tenido en los últimos
siete años, el goteo no alcanza
para permear a esos lugares
tan necesitados de soluciones.
La primera decisión de riesgo,
pero muy innovadora,
que tomamos fue separar
la política de la gestión.
En la política se hizo un
comité multidisciplinario
de todos los actores que iban
a participar en el plan.
La gestión se le encomendó
al Laboratorio Tecnológico del Uruguay
que yo presidía en aquella época
para la parte operativa.
Uds. dirán: "¿Qué tiene de innovador
separar la política de la gestión?",
es lo más lógico.
No lo tomen tan así.
En nuestros países hay una gran cantidad
de políticos haciendo gestión
y gestores haciendo política.
Y eso es el peor de los mundos.
Nos agarramos cada congestión
por eso que es brutal.
La otra decisión muy importante que tomamos
es que el sistema educativo
no iba a ser quien ejecutaba esto.
Uds. dirán: "¿Por qué?"
Porque el sistema educativo
¡no está preparado para esto!
No le podemos decir al sistema educativo:
"Tomen 300 000 máquinas,
o 100 000 o 50 000",
porque no están preparados,
van a discutir muchísimo,
después van a llamar consultores,
que a su vez llamarán
organismos internacionales,
que a su vez van a hacer
un pliego de condiciones
muy sofisticado donde van a entrar
muy pocos participantes.
Como le llamo yo la escalera
infinita de no tomar riesgos.
Y lo que va a pasar es que
la sociedad va a pagar
mucho más caro por el producto
de lo que vale.
Y nosotros que ya asumíamos los riesgos
y éramos los primeros en hacerlo
sabíamos perfectamente
que nadie sabía mejor
que nosotros como hacerlo,
entonces para que pagar y no resolver
nosotros el problema.
Obviamente, cuando lanzamos el proyecto
hubo dos grandes problemas o riesgos.
Uno: Los niños saben más que los maestros.
Los maestros estaban muy asustados
porque los niños sabían más que ellos.
Les tratamos de explicar
que obviamente eso era así
pero no iba a disminuir
su capacidad como educadores
porque el educando supiera más.
Yo le pregunto a los padres,
que levanten la mano
si han perdido autoridad por
pedirle ayuda a sus hijos.
Nadie.
Y a los hijos que ayudan a sus padres,
les pido que levanten la mano
si disfrutan hacerlo.
La mayoría.
Y eso se dio así en toda
la parte educativa.
El otro aspecto que para nosotros
fue importantísimo fue:
No presionar a los docentes.
Nosotros éramos conscientes
que si presionábamos a los docentes,
esto iba a terminar
inmovilizando el sistema.
Les dijimos: "Uds. van a recibir
una máquina igual que los niños",
(no se olviden niños y maestros de
escuela pública recibían una máquina).
"Empiecen a usar la máquina
como una herramienta,
luego poco a poco vayan modificando
eso para agregarle contenido
y modifiquen la currícula".
Y al no haberlos presionado, los maestros
vieron a los niños interactuar
y fue brutal, brillante, porque
se fueron motivando fuertemente.
Sin lugar a dudas tuvimos múltiples
críticas en aquel momento,
que era mucha plata, había
que resolver otras cosas,
por qué no darles de comer,
por qué no reformar las escuelas.
Y cuando yo le pregunto a la gente:
¿Vos le compraste una computadora
a tu hijo? Me dicen "Si".
Entonces ¿por qué cuando
el Estado decide
darle computadoras a todos los niños
del país se ponen en contra?
Cuando cada uno hace un esfuerzo para
comprarle una computadora a su hijo,
¿hace tanta discusión?
No creo.
En términos de qué hicimos,
qué desplegamos,
les aclaro desde primero de escuela
hasta primero de secundaria
todos tienen computadora.
La computadora es de ellos.
Eso es alrededor de 380 000, 98 %
de esos niños tienen conectividad.
140 000 niños no tienen que caminar
más de 300 metros para tener Internet.
A fin de año todos los niños van
a estar en esas condiciones.
Hemos capacitado más de 18 000 maestros.
Estamos trabajando en los asentamientos
para que haya Internet
en todos los hogares.
Tenemos un canal de TV para transmitir
las mejores prácticas educativas
y obviamente tenemos un portal educativo.
No se crean que todo es tan fácil,
esto se los cuento rápido,
tuvimos líos de todos los colores.
Para que las máquinas
no se comercialicen
tenemos un software
que bloquea la máquina
si se pierde o el niño no va a clase.
Un día se nos bloquearon 50 000
máquinas por un error nuestro.
No se imaginan el lío que tuvimos
para desbloquearlas una por una,
porque la clave es única
y no está en manos de los maestros
y menos en manos de los niños.
¿Cuánto nos costó?
Invertimos en torno a ciento
y pico millones de dólares.
Para no hacer muchos números
y mucha ensalada,
las computadoras nos costaron
alrededor de USD 188
y USD 60 nos costó todo lo demás:
servidores, conectividad, antenas,
Internet, despliegue,
servicio técnico, repuestos,
logística, entrega... todo.
Esto fue todo por licitación pública
(nacional e internacional).
Si tomamos cuatro años de
vida útil de la máquina
nos va a costar USD 75 por año,
de los cuáles USD 48 son la computadora
y USD 27 son todos los servicios adicionales
que requiere un proyecto de este tamaño.
Para que se hagan una idea,
en la etapa de despliegue eso
es menos del 5% del presupuesto
de la educación
y menos del 2 por 1000
del producto bruto.
Obviamente, después de hablar
de todo esto tengo que hablar
de los resultados, invertimos
más de USD 100 millones.
El primer resultado es: Se puede hacer.
El segundo resultado importante
es que tenemos 380 000 impactos,
no se los puedo contar todos
y no soy tan presumido
para decir que los conozco todos.
Tenemos impactos directos,
impactos indirectos,
impactos pensados e impactos
que no habíamos pensado para nada.
También hay muchas cosas que pasan,
que no podemos decir seriamente
o científicamente que pasan por CEIBAL.
También hay muchas cosas,
que si bien no podemos asegurar
que pasan solo por CEIBAL, tampoco
podemos decir CEIBAL no tuvo nada que ver.
Entonces muchos de los datos que tenemos
afirman una sola gran cosa:
valió la pena.
Valió la pena porque los niños
van más motivados a clase,
valió la pena porque hacen
los deberes con más motivación,
valió la pena porque repiten menos
en los lugares que pudimos medir
valió la pena porque les recuperamos
a miles de niños la identidad,
porque nosotros no entregábamos máquinas
si no tenían cédula de identidad o DNI
y eso implicaba tener que hacer trámites
para recuperar la identidad de los niños.
Valió la pena porque aumentó
la autoestima en muchísimos niños,
muchos niños aprendieron fotografía,
aprendieron cine,
aprendieron música y no había forma
que lo hubieran hecho
si no tenían esa herramienta.
Sin lugar a dudas que valió la pena
porque la escuela pública vuelve a ser
el pilar y el centro de los pueblos,
de los barrios y de los
departamentos del interior.
Y porque en esa escuela
pública los maestros
están reformulándose, dejaron
de ser un maestro Wikipedia
para transformarse en
un maestro motivador
y un maestro que quiere
hacer nuevas cosas.
Sin duda que valió la pena
porque los maestros
les enseñan a los niños,
y los niños a sus padres.
Por último, valió la pena
porque hemos transformado
un privilegio que era tener una computadora
en el año 2006 a un derecho.
Y ese cambio fue fundamental
para que todo el sistema político,
todos los agentes económicos
y toda la sociedad en general apoye
y se embandere con el proyecto.
Hoy tenemos miles de voluntarios
trabajando en las escuelas
y una cantidad de profesionales
de altísimo nivel
apoyándonos gratuitamente porque
creen en el proyecto.
No hay que ser exitista, recién
terminamos la primera etapa
todo lo que nos queda es mucho más.
En esta primera etapa lo que hicimos
fue la inserción tecnológica
en los hogares y en la escuela.
Nos queda todavía reinventar el aula,
reinventar la educación, el aprendizaje,
y hacer todo eso con los padres.
Hay una frase que usamos para
describir el estado de CEIBAL.
Decimos "Si CEIBAL fuera
una película de cine,
para los niños es una comedia, para
los padres una película de suspenso,
y para los maestros es un drama".
No les quepa la menor duda,
CEIBAL no resuelve todos
los problemas de Uruguay,
es simplemente una parte de la solución.
La tecnología permite
fermentar nuevas formas
de resolver las cosas
y nuevas ideas para apoyarlo.
También hay que tener claro,
que todo esto es un proceso lento,
nosotros tenemos acá tres variantes:
La variante social, la variante cultural
y la variante educativa.
Esas tres se mueven a distinta velocidad,
rápidamente vemos los impactos sociales,
más lentamente vemos
los impactos culturales
y obviamente mucho más lento vamos
a ir viendo los impactos educativos.
Solo trabajando sobre esos tres planos,
solo trabajando conjuntamente
esas tres cosas
podemos tener esperanza
de cambio, creer que ese cambio
va a ser posible y hacerlo.
Yo quiero antes de terminar
pasarles un video
porque hablar es fácil pero
las imágenes son mucho mejores.
(Video)
Maestro: No se olviden, el usuario
y la contraseña, ¿verdad?
Bueno dale, empezamos.
Maestra: Y acá que escribimos ¿qué?
Estudiantes: Un texto.
Maestro: ¿A ver qué mandos le dan a Uds.?
Maestro: Tienen que hacerla
mirar para allá: Left 120.
Estudiante: "Maestro mire".
Maestro: "Perfecto".
Maestra: Una maravilla,
la verdad una maravilla.
Maestra: Era impensable para
nosotros que desde el salón
pudiéramos entrar a museos mundiales,
entrar a bibliotecas, bajar mapas...
Niño: Hay veces que buscamos información,
imágenes sobre lo que trabajamos
Niño: Si cero es Y, es el centro
de la pantalla.
Maestra: Se usa para buscar trabajo
o para escribir poesías.
Niña: Mamá consiguió trabajo
con la computadora
y esa rutina que mamá
trabajaba día por medio
ahora cambió, porque mamá
trabaja toda la semana
gracias a un trabajo que le encontré.
Estudiante: Ahí está bien mirá.
Niña: Tú ves una partecita, así, donde
te ves tú porque acá tiene la cámara.
Niño: Le saco fotos a los animales,
a una liebre que tengo guacha,
a papá esquilando;
varias cosas hago con la computadora.
Maestra: Esto de llevarse a la casa la
computadora es propiamente de ellos,
reúne a la familia a la hora del mate,
preguntarle a mamá, es poder interactuar,
enseñarle alguna actividad
que bajó, que aprendió.
Maestra: Es cierto que los papás
se han interesado un poco más
por el seguimiento de los deberes
de los chiquilines, por ejemplo.
Madre: Antes él no quería ir a la escuela
y ahora que tiene la computadora me dice:
"Mamá yo voy a ir a la escuela".
¡Y llora para ir! Cualquiera de ellos 4.
Le enseña al hermano, a nosotros
cómo usar la computadora
y ahora pasa horas con ella.
Madre: Ellos nos enseñan a nosotros
cómo usarla, no nosotros a ellos...
Madre: Nosotros le tenemos que estar
preguntando: "¿Cómo se hace esto?"
Y él nos enseña a nosotros rapidísimo.
No sabemos hasta que él nos enseñe.
Hombre: Es una nueva forma de estudio
que antes no la teníamos nosotros.
Niño: Yo quiero ser diseñador
gráfico y poder diseñar programas
y hacer cosas en la
computadora que sirvan.
Maestra: Les estamos dando la
oportunidad de generar competencias
en algo que les van a pedir
en el mercado laboral.
Saben en qué páginas y cómo clasificar
en un buscador de Internet.
Son pequeñas herramientas que
mañana les van a ser útiles.
Es como que la escuela
va tomando el mismo ritmo
que la sociedad en la que está inserta
y en la que tiene una
responsabilidad increíble.
Niño: La escuela siempre me gustó,
y ahora con la computadora más.
(Fin Video)
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)